Oh McShea hey I'm here
hey doing buddy I'm here welcome I knew
the future I love a love manner machine
the fusion I now
I totally sang that in my video review
did you hear people watching today those
pretty great we're gonna play trials
fusee on a game that came out last week
the other has since had a bunch of what
the sweet user generated levels
installed including this disaster that I
found for Chris I got it you got it oh
good GameSpot's ellen laura anderson has
actually successfully beaten three beats
yes he did it over run at this i had
this i have found that the best my way
to do this it's just instantly roll
forward and hope for the best
well cuz there's no there's there's no
way to control out there fine look at
how long the drop in its so far down oh
my god oh my god you're gonna do it oh
it's 27 seconds beating i have to replay
it oh my god you're getting so close oh
my god there's also this little maneuver
you can do okay were you where you jump
off and then you go like this oh god
he's okay he's just a little flailing of
course he goes I'd be flailing we've got
like 20 more minutes of this segment I'm
gonna put down the controller and we're
just now the man flailing on the ground
I check out some more of the
user-generated
I love the user-generated tracks I just
gave us so give us a give us your
feedback on this video game transfusion
thirds and the Trials HD we chose
evolution this is our the the latest in
the console versions of the next-gen
they're all basically the same but it's
just like a 2d motorcycle game that's
kind of puzzle game and part racing part
platformer yeah
pitting out of genre for this
it doesn't really work but yeah and it's
all about like navigating these crazy
obstacle courses hey there's me there's
Google food here I see you and it's and
it's got a crazy level editor like the
developers told me and they could have
been lying who knows they told me that
they made every single one of the tracks
in the game through this editor anaconda
yeah I think it said that with evolution
- you can do it it's so crazy now
granted I could do nothing but people
who are talented can do everything in it
I remember what evolution people were
making like games that weren't even
trials anymore
oh yeah I'm pong and stuff yeah you can
hold I mean in in trials itself you can
play like a first-person maze and
there's like a flappy bird knockoff and
stuff like this always flappy bird and
10-years people give you like 100
personal record won the gold medal no
worries Tom that was just your scores go
for it
totally she was right on national
television international yes right yeah
I think it's honest easy this is a fine
CBS program we're bumping off the price
is right
they actually erased a lot of my tracks
that I favorited already which is a
shame pourquoi why is that I think
there's a lot of servers issues with
this game really it's weird like
yesterday I couldn't connect at all to
the game or just to the the
user-generated stuff like I couldn't
connect to the game yesterday
I don't know we there's weird issues but
hopefully there is this one okay we're
at the everyone we're into like oh hello
this is this is a hard track I am a very
good right here you're you're okay yeah
used to be doing all right here I'm
better than you are you're not as good
as max over are you sure cousin I'm
wrong no well for instance he passed
this level cool how many tries it it
taken took him a lot that's not this
parts the easy part is this I'm eating
meters this is necessary this is a real
I think this is a gate that's track is
aesthetically pretty ugly
whoa but I think that it is pretty
brilliant in some of the obstacles okay
well I want to show this one but yeah
it's tough to make things that are good
looking and good playing I'll see the
thing with the really hard trials ones
is that at least I know the developer
made them so I know I can complete oh
yeah whereas I be terrified on these
user Jen
like this guy didn't play test this
properly you have to you have to be able
to pass it like you can't actually
upload a user-generated level until your
passes already a jump is hard but fake
thank you for giving me credit that this
is I want talking this I want people
understand that is all yeah but the
tough jump yeah
oh God what no nailed it neither now
we're supposed to go nailed it nailed it
have them get the money out of it or do
I go just couple lower do nailed it
you can do either one but you can go
below yeah see you bet and then you got
to go straight up just gonna be a hard
[ __ ] Oh your head you're poor goddamn
head oh my god this is oh have you
unlocked any of the cat heads with you
you play points yet you know I'm pretty
sure those are squirrel heads damaged ok
and caliber did but those things freak
me out
ok I have nightmares about nightmares
was that when Ray Mears appears new
nightmares what the hell is a ray Mir a
soccer player no go to rugby blue hair
that's my go to I have no idea who
Danny's talking about oh you know who he
wasn't be appeared in your nightmares
crazy a Primus he announced himself
Prairie air he goes Chris I'm rabia's
I'm in your nightmare I was how you
making this so hard
look man sometimes things are hard is he
the prime minister of Ireland
I thought Ray Mears is a famous person
yes he does like one of those travel
shows in the UK where he goes off to
Australia needs kangaroos [ __ ] oh so
he's like the Rick Steves of the UK yeah
why Chris the the definition of insanity
is doing the same thing over and over
and expecting different results
Oh somebody's watch that contemporary
movie no I
I took a high school psych class thank
you very much Mike
yeah is that one you like you give
somebody the ball and you pull it back
and go psych for like four years and
they give you a diploma the end of it
yeah that's American education in a
nutshell and then the teacher was like
you get an A not because I have totally
topical humor they would still enjoy
Christmas try a different level yeah
you're bad looks just let me let me go
outside Parrish next I thought I could
like trust you why would you ever think
to entertain future because I regularly
defeat your scores doesn't mean you
could trust me to entertain people
you chose the Xbox one version so you
could avoid head-to-head competition
that's the biggest thing about trials
yeah week one just just so different to
be the last one I want no Cooper it's
not super into him or whatever
TK he'll Panda I loved it too girlfriend
yeah so I'd like to yeah the whole thing
is leaderboard chases yeah
why why are there cross-platform
leaderboards yes are we grilling him but
we've gotta say like is that a bit what
do you what do you see the AMA handle
for that like control like difference in
control difference in whatever systems
etc most of the time I think it's just
because developers don't care okay whoa
just make like who is it really
benefiting like it doesn't it benefit
them or like have everyone on the same
if you want it so badly I'm literally
considering just buying a it on ps4 as
well so how much is that is Charles
ninety bucks and there's a twenty bucks
season pass which seems a little crazy
by you know when you consider to the
game is 20 yeah why you can tell is a
user generated track because a is
impossible now okay don't worry I got
this you got it you can do it you might
be able to do it if they said what's
gonna be on the season I don't know more
tracks whether it's a trial game yeah
okay much more trash what I was gonna be
on more story I will coordinate of
course devote much of my working hours
to like covering that's what I want to
do there is kind of a story in trials
fusion ya know it's weird isn't it but
well let's let's not spoil any of that
let's let's do it super spoil story the
rich fiction of trial yeah alright of
like portal me it's not as good riding
on I'm going don't stop all this we're
gonna do some multiplayer here circle
yeah because that's the other wonderful
if it is about right rooftop runners you
know number four thank you
so a we've we've set up a new camera and
I believe it's a game spots own Dharma
horik
hey so if the audio levels doesn't work
don't work too good for this section
it's because Dan's not doing is dark job
do your job so where we go over here cuz
Vipers the faster oh no I take a lie he
chose the box bat did I good Patrick one
for doing tricks do you know we're doing
tricks in this no of course you don't
have you played this not the multiplayer
in Charles fusion no okay you review
evolution yes welcome to the fusion I'm
the real guy I'm blue I'm third from the
bottom god there's some high saturation
going on here yeah a second job
saturated oh damn it damn it I'm but
slidin see you later nerds I said just
me or did they do they scream you're a
lot more in this game than they did an
evolution are their vocal oh really
their vocal they're like oh god damnit
nerds so you get minus points for for
being the the right for fighting you
know you don't have to stay at the
checkpoint because otherwise nothing
would ever get done
we have Baylor finishes on goddamnit oh
I'm really bad if it's even Mary's
laughing eventually very even Mary she's
usually very nice and does not mock
people she's known for but I'm terrible
that's obviously have not played a game
with Mary oh come on you oh god damn it
no [ __ ] oh we finished for I did I did
thank God oh thank god
ah you dnf'd Dan no finish it that's
what it that's what that says dad dad no
finish yeah
dan doesn't have a microphone on but he
can he can give a vote you can do like
physical how do you feel about that one
dan Roach whoa we just select the same
level again come on you boners time
doing the famous hmd sign there
I don't understand your UK slang HMV
don't ask donõt ask donõt follow up with
questions about them ticular wait wait a
bit back yet okay now why are these all
rooftop runners are they're just
different versions of the same whatever
what our fusion cross I'm pressing X on
ROI press the start rate I'm not picking
the Fox spot this time I'm gonna fix the
T repair and there's also was the
bicycle in here okay grab it after this
we're all doing bicycle it's all done
bicycles okay don't don't don't what
don't jerk out don't jerk I don't I
don't even understand what that is and I
don't want to permanent the kids are
using this this terminology is is that
who told Tom about Urban Dictionary or
didn't I have two things on urban
dictionary if he was on our prediction
what hmd was dirty sure things are dirty
what's what - what are you - things on
urban dictionary one of them is an
opportunity is it like I had an
opportunity to see alien colonial
Marines okay and the other one is
coincidence which is like in a musical
and everybody just breaks out dancing
there's some very good yeah I invented
that did you did you invent munching
know that sounds really why is
everything so filthy when you're sad
most of it is filthy
what did Annie says oh oh what is going
on there what is one thing is you know
you don't ask what it is now go come on
you're heavier user one done mejor ik in
the control room
are you playing with tape delay as well
okay nice to work he's using wall hacks
I can we do bicycles this time for doing
bicycle everyone do bicycles rabbit it
means you to Mike oh I guess I just
cycles through them get it is now run
race two of six yeah you could have said
that earlier Mike yeah I don't remember
these things I do it's not the focus of
my own my wings this is difficult this
is difficult is there it's great is
there a multiplayer of this nature I'm
in the full in the hey guys you asking
is there some multiplayer in a in the
the full retail bird because I wasn't in
the beta what what are you talkin is
there multiplayer in this game
playing this game and it smells like
Naoko like online oh now okay this is
the most confusing sorry like how do I
answer this does this game have bicycle
oh yeah I mean I had online multiplayer
and of evolution apparently it wasn't
super popular so that just cut it out
yeah I couldn't even remember that it
wasn't in the previous game yeah no
every single there's not like a sports
leagues and dedicated to this if there's
eSports if if Dreamhack is accepting
goat simulator I feel like this should
at least be given a nod react yeah
Dreamhack yeah I came third I got last
and but I got not last
oh man it's Dan's voice here Oh God look
Dan sitting in silence and total focus
back there well we're all trying to keep
up super entertaining and witty banter
you have like a minion minion army back
there what are we already doing this
time oh I picked the Panda actually I'm
sorry put it a baggie
I got stuck holding the bag II don't
work out in the baggy Tom even playing
this game there for quite a while let's
take two weeks are you bored of it yet
no it's hard to be bored of it because
it's really good and there's a bunch of
different tracks there's a lot of tracks
there's a lot of all there's like 2000
user-generated travel really all of them
are good every single one every single
one of the troubled acclaim I'll make
sure they do see in the bunch not
another bad one yeah I'm gonna put one
of my own in there shocking make you
liar I really want to make a system Wars
piece where it's like we compare the
user tracks of the different systems is
it fair to say that it is we'll see
who's the best career the TV is Opie
yeah is it fair to say that this
ultimate vehicle is totally Opie because
I feel like it is and I'm driving it
it's the slowest yeah but it's like but
easy by far they're like easiest to
control I mean I the same like every
single time I win cuz I'm the best and
I'm on my ATV because that's the way
races are I don't know I chose a
different one
oh nice work dad also I love how humble
you are
he says raise three of six but the only
track bucket back at back at still
almost beat you with a 5/8 oh no its
pipeline pressure is the next one the
next fine I don't know there's a lot of
stuff going on if you've any questions
about trials views er you should
probably know already who's been a per
week but please Peter you could see
myself I'll be sure to answer them when
you do it when I'm not trying to race
hard
we should do some like upside down
racing up there Oh No yeah so there's
like a bunch of modifiers in the in the
single-player ones that allow you to do
like upside down upside down and like
driving from directly behind you but it
still uses left and right - it's so
crazy remember those
so we talked last week about the oh
maybe the ATV is okay remember all the
different challenges that are in each
level oh yeah we had a long conversation
about that how many of those have you
actually done all of them really
no I did the upside down one do diddly
and then I also teamed up with van to do
that also so these are like very
difficult challenges for every single
three optional challenge for every level
and some of them are like do 10 flips
but on a 0 fault run which is generally
kind of easy but then it's like do 5
flips on an extreme track and Lord help
you trying to find a place to do that
we're gonna flip on those things alright
then there's these ones that are like
stop the flowers have you guys ever
tried no yeah I have to like drive over
oh so it flowers so those are I mean
those are very exploration heavies yeah
that figure out where to go and then
there's like find warp zones which can
be kind of hard time and then the warps
yeah finding them computer and then
completing them is impossible except for
the first warp zone this is what my
assessment is it is literally impossible
oh man everyone do a flip it's a little
late you talk about the the new trick
system that's been put in transfusion -
there's a new trick system is put on
trial fusion - yeah
nailed it nailed it what else you need
it now
yeah okay you can do a trick bunch of
guys rabid euro and Superman it's like
on the left-right go way down right yeah
and I win to hell I think yeah and it's
like kind of like with the risk of using
it really don't worry to explain this
dynamic no it's not like buttons you hit
to do like a backflip it's our yeah you
got you got a synergize and think
outside the box
no you brought on your cell phone wire
look at you how are those trick levels
are they oh they're fantastic yeah
that's all speed and jumping that's all
that's all it is it's not much like
they're fine like the trick stuff how
I'm mad I knew how finicky I'm not a
huge it's finicky but it's also just
goofy fun it's pretty goofy if you want
super precision than you look at me I'm
doing something I did something to I
think unless unless you think I'm you
and I think I'm I'm at the back okay I'm
second from the back guys yeah we're the
only fun ones everyone else is like a
dope we are hmm I'm gonna race oh god I
murdered my dude I'm just trying to come
in not last here that's all guys are you
having fun making if not fun for anyone
else did everyone lean forward
I want everybody finished that one
before me cuz I'm gonna come and not
last and then try to do a triple s you
totally did come and laugh at that one
even I am not overall on the winner
Danny oh do I - thanks Sony for having
me make a new account because I moved to
America Cheers
I'm bitter about you don't seem very
happy about that - often ah what is this
what is this pyrosequencing I don't know
that it I don't know what it is don't
ask me don't ask me questions like you
answer ask me about the name of the game
and other things I know what's the name
of this game files fusion can you click
on pyrosequencing and see what happens
it's not up yet sequencing and compiled
initiating starter platoons hold for
nanopore sequencing upgrade I don't know
what it is absolutely like in a complete
re-review or something when it comes out
right redlynx I'm like dudes a week with
the game really make sure I understand
it listen to the menu music like for
another four hours just not entirely
pawn right of five thousand word essay
on man-machine the future I know I
really wish I would have had that song
at my wedding
Wow did you marry a printer I would have
had to delete that or some sort of
atomic or a man I want to know what the
fusion was there
you're as about the fusion at Toms
wedding so this is an extreme track
these are hard I don't want to see me
fail to do stuff yeah you came to the
right place yeah I mean this one's not
super bad nice work nice work crocodile
so like that's a flower like this is a
fluff is that a flower that you have to
like I don't know I always want to see
like this one of the things here is to
stomp all the way down there okay so
like boom let's get that but I don't
know if it's like it's isn't gonna reset
no doesn't I just have to thank God tag
right they said they'd do it once good
that would be literally impossible yeah
I nailed it I mean I got up so well so
this is what I then spend like yeah it's
like 10:30 at night I'm just gonna like
play trials for a few minute oh and then
like 130 rolls around and I've been
trying to do a friggin extreme track for
three hours and it's the timer has
already gotten up to half an hour I
think it caps out at 300 tries really
it's a half hour and 500 you're kidding
you've actually reached that yes yeah
not in this not I did in evolution not
in this one I've I've reached it nailed
it
now nope now that you really have to do
what you're doing the first time it's
better you can't slow down you have to
be better at the game I love I mean
probably watching this must be this one
out there grace you got three more time
three more thrice tries thrice
there you go point he's done done okay
you've got three worth rise rise of this
bit I can't say two words running yeah I
know this it's not a hate you never get
over it
you really say how do you say Shh hey
Shh hey Chet like a nahi SHhhh
yeah like I'm very similar to that page
oh I can't get past that oh alright you
got three more tries at this hold on let
me hit let me stomp that flower real we
got it leet yeah now that dang it two
more tries yeah you're making thing one
more try Lee pressure full pressure full
of words
all right it says wordsmith atomic che
oh I'm sorry as well no no all right
unlucky that is trials fusion Tom McShea
thank you very much coming on thanks for
having me so we're doing this is a
weekly segment now right 20 minutes of
trying to stomp flour yeah cool
challenge